so I went back to Vogelbaum and I
managed to squeeze the truth out of him
the real truth. what was that plan again
oh well wakey wakey hey buddy you're out
for quite a while you can thank me for
saving you some time later but for now
time to get out come on you're going to
love this mom Wow look at this handsome
devil hey pal you know who I am
homelander, yeah that's right
hey everybody is Charlie this is going to
be my video for Amazon's the boys I've
gotten a lot of requests to do a video
for the series so hopefully you've had a
chance to see it but if you're brand new
to my channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos it did get renewed
for season two so yes there will be a
season two the showrunner has even
talked about some of the really WTF
stuff from the comic book that they plan
on doing during season 3 so it does
sound like they have a chance of doing
every single thing from the comic book
over the next couple of seasons but as
you probably saw during season 1 they
changed a bunch of big things they
pulled way back because the comic is way
more graphic than any of the hardcore
stuff that you saw in the TV series
careful for spoilers from the boys
season 1 if you have not seen the series
yet because we'll be talking about very
specific details home Landers secret
plan that he's been enacting all season
as well as all the big things that they
reveal at the end of the season in these
scenes here but if you're a little
confused about what's going on it's
basically meant to be a dark parody of
the Justice League and DC characters
what happened was is that when Garth
eNOS created the series with dick
Robertson they were publishing it
through Wildstorm at DC Comics but
because of the subject matter and how
graphic they got with the stuff that
homelander who's basically a dark
version of Superman and all the other
heroes who are analogs of Justice League
characters were doing the DC was just
not comfortable with them publishing so
they cancelled the comic book series
after six issues and Garth eNOS had to
take the comic book to another publisher
which wound up being Dynamite
Entertainment and they finished the rest
of the 72 issues so there's 72 issues
total so I'm guessing they'll get
through almost all the comic book stuff
within three or four seasons so starting
with number 5 the ending here butcher is
confronting homelander hoping that he
can either force him to stand trial or
get rid of him somehow but the thing is is
that the compound v superheroes within
this world don't really have weaknesses
like the heroes inside the DC Universe -
like Superman has kryptonite but in the
world of the boys there is no kryptonite
home Lander is virtually invulnerable so
you find that people get creative in
trying to control him using various
means
so homelander has this really weird
messed-up relationship with
Stillwell butcher knows that and he's
going to try and use Stillwell to try and
get home later
what he wants him to do but what butcher
doesn't know in this scene is that
homelander himself also has a vendetta
against Stillwell and his sort of turned
against Vaught American a little bit
because of Secrets that he's learned
about his own past so you have three
really big long-running plots all
converging in this moment here homelander
are learning secrets about himself
butcher learning secrets about his past
and still well and Vaught learning
secrets that homelander has been
keeping from them within the world of
the boys pretty much everyone is
double-crossing everyone else supers and
regular people like butcher is
double-crossing and lying to all the
people that he's working with homelander
is lined all the people that he's
working with Stilwell is lined all the
people that she's working with so I was
a little surprised by how quickly they
were revealing some of these big things
from later on in the comic book but
number four a quick back story butchers
reason for hating homelander is because
butcher believes that homelander
assaulted and impregnated his wife a
long time ago preceding the events of
season 1 so he's had this long-running
vendetta against homelander for a long
time eventually what happened is is that
through the government he formed a team
called the boys then later they just
went so off the rails and got so
hardcore in trying to police superheroes
that the government disavowed butcher in
the boys and he's been running this side
operation on the DL this whole time but
he's trying to get back in the good
graces of the government because now
he's finally learned about the secret of
compound V in where all these
superheroes come from so he believes
that he has enough compelling evidence
to force all these supers to stand trial
and turn the public against them because
like I said there are no real natural
weaknesses that homelander has so you
can't get rid of him unless you have someone
that's stronger than him which I'll get
to in a second because like I said lots
of big secrets being revealed you just
meant to believe at the end of season 1
that there is literally nothing that can
end homelander for right now they can
only attack him in psychological and
emotional ways but Vaught always does
have a second plan like I said everyone
is double-crossing everyone else so Vaud
has been double-crossing homelander
this whole time we see a flashback
watching the person that we learned to
be butcher's wife seemingly giving birth
to home Landers baby but you're led to
believe that she died during childbirth
butcher
later explains that she either
terminated pregnancy then offed herself
or the baby ended her but he hasn't seen
her in years so he assumes that she died
the worst possible that she could have
he feels like he has nothing left to
lose that's why he's using these crazy
last-ditch attempts the reason why
homelander is confronting Stilwell in
this scene now the reason why he hates
them is because he just learned a deep
secret about his past that they've been
using to control him the whole idea is
that he's so valuable to this company's
balance sheet he earned so much money
for them that they'll do anything to
keep him toeing the line so that they
don't lose any potential money in the
whole idea of season 1 is that they're
trying to get the military in the US
government to start using superheroes
and funding their programs the
government doesn't really like
superheroes they don't trust them the
military generals don't want to have
anything to do with them because they
believe that the superheroes are loyal
to Vaught because they're on their
payroll of course the right to not trust
the superheroes they're terrible
so Vaught has been doing everything it
can was still well to try and get them
to accept the superheroes but we also
learned that homelander has been
trying to do the same thing by himself
with a secret long-running plan that
I'll talk about in a second but that's
not exactly why he's really pissed off
it's still well and bought here this is
mostly about Vaught and Stilwell lying
to him about his potential love child
with butcher's wife one of the other
long-running beliefs that he has during
the series growing up is that they told
him that he's not capable of fathering
children because if he were to ever have
a child then his loyalty might be to
that child and not to the company
anymore he might leave them so they just
lied to him that it's not possible for
him to have children so it's sort of
twist him up inside and informed some of
the reasons why he's so dark like maybe
he wouldn't be so hardcore if he
believed that he could have a family of
his own
there are a couple of moments during the
series where they try to get you to
sympathize with homelander they show
you his life as a child no one would hug
him they just kept him in the middle of
the secret safe room because as a baby
he was so powerful that he be British
they accidentally used his powers on
someone he could destroy an entire room of
people even as an infant like this he
had a terrible childhood which is part
of the reason why he's such a psychopath
and present day everything that he says
about his backstory
is all a fabrication from bought the
real secret of all these superheroes is
that they were all created in a lab as
babies but people have been trying to
test whether or not you can turn adults
into superheroes using compound B but
number two the big WTF reveal and that
end credits scene is butcher learning
that his wife did not die and eventually
gave birth successfully to home Landers
love child
so he's revealing himself to this little
kid I'm your father and you have
butchers former wife are still why
because technically I guess they didn't
get divorced seeing butcher there and
you can see this worry on her face like
they don't want to completely demonize
her it seems like maybe she didn't want
to terminate the child because it was
literally trying to claw its way out of
her belly the last you saw but it sounds
like because she was just so torn up and
didn't know what to do she just went
running and just trying to been living
in isolation and raised this child by
herself but she just doesn't want to
deal with all the craziness and doesn't
want anything to do with home Lander and
seems too remorseful to want to confront
butcher about the whole thing she's
meant to be more of a victim of the
situation but because all these secrets
are literally coming out in the light of
day now you have to deal with it during
season two homely under sort of throws
this in butchers face so home leaders
trying to tell butcher that the whole
reason you've been doing this big
crusade of yours creating the boys and
doing all these things during season one
it's all because of a lie
you shouldn't be hating me for the
reason that you hate me right now
although home lander is still a pretty
terrible person and there's a number of
other reasons why you'd be justified and
wanting to get rid of him but number one
the big long-running planned that home
lander has been enacting this whole time
lying to Vaught he eventually comes
clean to Stilwell about what he's been
doing is this because of this plan to
get superheroes in the military we
learned that home lander has been using
a train to run compound v2 terrorist
cells all over the world making it seem
like there are threats all over the
world then the military will have to let
them in because of all these terrorists
have their own superheroes then think
about the damage they could cause the
only way to fight superheroes is with
another superhero this also gets into
another big idea about how you get rid
of homelander but homelander wants
to prove himself that he's really smart
because this whole time they just sort
of treat him like he's a dummy homelander
resents them for this and he also takes
measures to protect
detect his plan early on there's another
politician from Baltimore who's thinking
about bringing superheroes into his city
to protect it because crime is getting
so bad he learns the secret about
compound B and threatens to tell the
public about it on his own homelander
goes and secretly destroys him while he's
on his flight to prevent him from
letting that secret out so that the
public won't eventually learn about his
own secret compound V plan and talk
about things coming full circle at the
beginning of the series Huey's fiance is
destroyed by a train when he just runs
right through her without paying
attention we don't find out what he was
doing till later it was running compound
V all those cells around the
world as part of homelander's grand
plan so all these characters are deeply
connected by a bunch of secrets that
each of them are keeping from the other
people involved getting into season two
there's still a lot of big comic book
reveals that they have not done on the
TV show yet you still meant to believe
that homelander is completely
invincible that is not completely true
and because now butcher knows about the
existence of homelander's son there's
another question that's raised which is
a change from the comic books as to what
butcher is going to do about homelander
her son is he going to threaten his life
to try and get homelander to do what
he wants him to do or is he going to be
more sympathetic because technically his
wife is still alive he still loves his
wife and this child belongs to his wife
so hurting the child would also hurt his
wife
so when answering a lot of these big
long-running questions they also raise
even bigger questions for them to answer
during season 2 but post all your
reactions in the comments below let me
know what you thought of the boys season
one it is a nice change of pace if
you've been watching more traditional
superhero fare all the Marvel the pg-13
stuff this is meant to be hard R and
like I said they pulled way back on the
comic book if you want the full
uncensored version just read the comic
book but if you have any big questions
about the series just leave them in the
comments I'm working on new Marvel and
new DC that should post pretty soon but
click here to learn about Batman Beyond
coming to the flash season 6 and crisis
on Infinite Earths
and click here for my Deadpool 3 teaser
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight!